[Music]
this is star talk cosmic queries edition
i'm your host neil degrasse tyson your
personal astrophysicist and we can't do
cosmic queries without chuck nice chuck
welcome back
and by the way
you could and
you said you can't i was just lying i'm
sorry i was lying
you're being kind to me you're being
kind and i appreciate
you know you're like we couldn't do this
without chuck knights but i've actually
seen shows where you have
okay
damn call me i thought i could slip that
one by but apparently not okay
uh but good to have you chuck and we
we've got a special guest we i guess
we've never had and i don't know how she
came
under our radar for so many years we've
got ali ward with us allie welcome to
star talk i'm here i'm i'm so happy to
um to incite such excited stammering
here i am no one can believe i'm here
least of all me
hi
so you've got quite the thing going on
you've you've taken ownership of all the
ologies of the universe and have
delivered them back to us in digestible
bites not only in your twitter stream
but in podcasts and and videos
so this is just i love it and and but
this is not your first rodeo really
right you've been at this psy ed stuff
for a while
um
what was innovation nation what was that
oh i'm still doing it we're on uh season
eight right now and now ouch one i know
season eight going into season nine any
second now so is there anything is there
any any fear you might run out of
innovations
no they keep inventing them that's the
wonderful thing
is people keep making stuff so who knows
what do you have going on what do you
have going on netflix brainchild what's
that about yeah so um innovation nation
is on cbs it's with mo raqqa it's
different innovations and then on
netflix i'm on brainchild which is a
kids science show and 100 humans and i
consult on a new show called ada twist
scientists that's coming out pretty soon
i'm very excited about it and a what
scientist uh aydah twist science that's
a person right she's yes yes it's an
animated person yes it's an animation
well i thought you said aid a twisted
scientist
okay you're fine um
just going to say that aydah does have
her problems so you might be right
and what is did i mention invention
what's that oh that's another show that
i host for cw and uh
what's
a little crazy and uh i've been working
with the obama's company to higher
ground doing some consulting for uh
waffles and mochi so i don't name drop
did i
every once in a while you know michelle
and barack just come by and
i mean you know i'm not i'm not saying
anything i'm just you know every once in
a while they'll
we talk and we talk about you know mochi
and waffles while we actually eat
waffles it's awesome it's just amazing
but
wait wait wait so also
uh okay wait mochi that's that japanese
candy is that right yes yes that's the
name of a of a kid's show all about food
and nutrition right mrs obama is right
because because you're also a food
person
i did something
i did some work for cooking channel i
had a job for cooking channel where they
made me go to bakeries and eat like 16
donuts a day and describe them which is
great the first couple seasons
close to mochi and waffles and it was
called chicken and waffles you're gonna
die so
you're gonna die
wait so after the second season they
would just roll you to the to the next
bakery yeah you'd be on an off camera
you'd be on an insulin drip it was uh
it's pretty intense
pretty intense i'm much happier in the
science base
but yeah so i juggle all these things
and the worst part about all of the jobs
is that i like them all and so i don't
know which ones to quit so i just stay
up late and work on everything i just
drink a lot let me say something if i ca
if i can just i don't sound like you
know
father time on the porch on the rocking
chair but uh you have a background
that would not immediately indicate that
you do exactly this
but your background is all the
background you need to do exactly this
right so so they're people they're
they're students who study acting
because they want to be an actor right
so they go to law school going to be a
lawyer business school you're in
business and you do these things and now
you invented all of this stuff because
that is that melange of talent now
unique to you
and that can only manifest in products
that are the unique paw print of what
you bring to it
that makes me feel a lot better about
job security i'll have to say
well that's your parents who said where
did we go wrong
she's not under me but i mean you know i
think that
really one thing i've learned from ology
so much is that the people that i
interview are so passionate about what
they study whether they're a buffologist
studying toads or they're someone who is
a fire ecologist or whatever they tend
to really love their jobs and so i think
i've really
learned from doing ologies is figure out
what you love the most and then just
gravitate toward that because you're
going to be the best at passionology so
yeah the study of watching people get
excited about their work i just invented
an ology right so there
i can actually use that now that you've
said it i can use it
i didn't invent it you did maybe maybe
there's an analogy for my passion
buttology is there
you know who i had on i did do
glutealogy with natalya reagan who has
been on star track a bunch so she yes
we've been yes she's a friend of star
talk we talked all about butts we talked
because the primate but the whole thing
with the orangutan yep tactile and
glutealogy and the mandrel the yeah the
big red
glutealology that's what it's called
theology glutathione so do humans have
the biggest butts humans have the
biggest butts right all the way primates
and i'm going to use first person plural
on that i'm going to include myself on
that we do have
right that's very kind of
the juiciest it's very inclusive of you
yes it is
you're a big fine primate when you back
that thing up
and for a reason so yeah you can listen
to um to her episode learn all about it
but that's kind of i realized i was
really good at being curious and and
just nosy enough to be uncomfortable in
some situations so it turns out you need
that because that cat should be on the
the edge of your comfort zone which is
always important otherwise nothing new
shows up and what did you study in
school
i studied science i loved science and i
also loved fine art and so i was
studying illustration and science and i
couldn't decide which way to go and i
thought maybe i would do both but i
ended up um as a double major in biology
and film and so i yeah kind of tv and
science ended up working yeah it's so
funny
you're keeping it you're the full
manifestation of that that's great and
then she if you notice neil if you
notice there's a very distinct dichotomy
in her choices
one actually pays money where you can
get a job and the other one does it
so
she's like fine art and science which
one can i live on
which one
biology and television
i mean ask a grad student though there
are grad students listening saying do
you know how much grad students make
wait allie let me put chuck in his place
here i can put checks in this place
please do your fine art
infuses
the depth and elegance of everything
else you do
so no you may not be specifically making
money from the fine art everything else
you're doing is enhanced by it yeah i
tried to say that i tried to tell my
mother that
when i went in about comedy i tried i
tried to do the same thing neil did not
work did not work okay she's like you
need to infuse some money into this rent
that's good there isn't there is an
ology for that gelatology is a study of
humor and i interviewed someone who
told me he was it's uh dr burke down in
loma linda he studies the effects of
laughter on on medical patients and he
is a man who is serious about laughter
and it was one of the driest interviews
i've ever done which i thought was
absolutely perfect because he's so wait
wait so
wait wait wait wait so
so if you say i was laughing so hard i
was in stitches
that would have extra meaning to him
probably would it probably i think
because if i if or or if i bust out my
stitches i don't want to laugh too hard
you know if i'm in the hospital trying
to recover i don't want chuck two near
me because i might laugh
you could just say i was laughing so
hard i was lengthening my telomeres is a
better way to say it oh good
longer when you laugh is that the deal
yeah that's the deal okay yeah you want
to you want to the telomeres are good
good but chuck you we have questions for
you is that right that is right
from our fan base this was so much fun i
forgot we were doing a uh the cosmic
queries
cosmic queries yeah yes what do you have
for us okay so uh let's just start off
with adam krauther or crother it's
c-o-c-r-o-w and then thur so krauther
krother i don't know anyway
he says thank you for this opportunity
to ask the question chuck you never know
so you never know
so
so okay go on i wish i could refute that
i can't you can't okay here we go okay
he says thank you for the opportunity to
ask this question i have friends and
family who have been convinced that
coveted vaccination is useless against
the disease and it will be harmful to
our health they are motivated by the
general distrust of conventional
medicine and faith and alternative
so-called holistic and spiritualistic
healing methods and their strong belief
in the paranormal
so
um he says how
do i approach
this discussion
adam
so you're a person who studies
everything
everything yeah so how do you what do
you what do you bet how do you
how
essentially let me back up let me better
formulate this
each of the fields that you
dip your toes in or or full body in
require
some
sensitivity to the vocabulary the jargon
the what's interesting what's not and so
you have to think this through and
somewhere in there you would have come
up with methods tools and tactics of
communicating what needs to get out
there so what have you what can you
share with us on this topic
well you know i was lucky enough to
study biology and i used to read a lot
of
journals for fun when i was in college i
was
a dork so luckily i have that kind of
background but um you know things like
this when it comes to communicating
science that i always try to start from
is just empathy and understanding where
someone's coming from whether it is
asking a scientist to share their work
or whether it's trying to get these
ideas to the public and so i think
of course there's things that are
infuriating about this but if
you are
with someone who does not want to
understand science or is blocked to it
always come from an empathetic
standpoint of what are they scared of i
think typically fear is what blocks us
off from a lot of learning so what do
they say this would come from
psyche
yes
analogy indeed
um
am i good am i good loved it loved it
haven't done that episode yet
too brought a topic
the idea that the empathy
at least doesn't have them dig their
heels in more strongly
you might be able to find a place to
have that conversation yeah i mean a
space a conversational space yeah
there's no you don't do any good if you
are um
if you are
being condescending to someone or
patronizing or if you are annoyed at
them for their beliefs doesn't do anyone
good you don't get it doesn't help
anyone well i'm doing this whole thing
wrong because i have i have the fred
samford uh
approach shut up dummy
shut up
yeah he did say that didn't he yeah
does not open a lot of mind so try to
address what they're scared of and then
try to perhaps talk to them about how
scary the other alternative is which you
know in this in terms of vaccinations so
what you're saying is
you're an idiot is not a good opener
i fight
no
we have to get you back on another show
the week before thanksgiving
before everyone goes home yes so that
the thanksgiving dinner conversations
can so no one dies yeah right we'll have
the special yeah
i have two allergies for you though we
do have vaccine infodemiology um which
premiered in january has a lot of
information has a lot of talk about
vaccine hesitancy and where those come
from from historical psychological place
and agnetology which is the study of
willful ignorance which is a real study
and i talked to a stanford professor
about that so those episodes are there
in case you want to understand why some
people just
okay very good i like i like the
overview there very good we got to take
a quick break when we come back more q a
with the queen of ologies
ally ward on star talks
we're back star talk cosmic queries
edition i got chuck with me and chuck we
have a guest i don't know how we missed
her the past eight years that we've been
doing
uh ali ward welcome welcome to star talk
and here how do we find you on twitter
just at ologies on everything i sat on
those handles i got them they're mine
ologies so you own ology i do i do i
couldn't believe the i don't know if
that's a good thing or a bad thing i
have to think about that it's a good
thing
if you turn evil
then to control the ologies is you
become a superhero
nemesis
no that's my plan yeah my plan is to
read everything
uh you're just seeing part of my
backstory now so if someone's gonna
wrong me and then i'm gonna use energy
story right now
so chuck we have to be nice to her
because no telling what powers jesus we
might turn her into an evilologist yep
right yeah lightning's gonna come out of
my eyes i'm gonna own the world it's
gonna be great there you go
so chuck we we solicited questions
specifically for her in this unheard
ology
universe so what do you have there uh
this is chapter lift shits who says uh
hey what's up stellar start talk crew
neil and chuck chester lipschitz here
with the question about ancient science
clearly man made discoveries before
language even though they did not
formally fall into today's definition of
science
do you think there would have been a
limit to the advancement of civilization
without language
oh
interesting
i like that
so ali have you interviewed any any any
linguists or anybody who's thought about
this language in the brain and
i haven't i haven't but i want to say
obviously
i guess it depends on how you define
language because there are so many
animals that use
language and have different ways of
communicating so are you talking are
they talking about just written language
are they talking about um like certain
syntax because there's i mean there are
different primates there are monkeys and
uh that have different dialects in terms
of where they grow up in certain ways
i'm thinking every species of animal on
earth has no trouble communicating with
other members of its species
all right i mean you look at ants and
bees and birds and and they're just
having a doing fine and i bet cavemen
or you know the cave people
they without a dictionary in a language
in a school i'm sure they
communicated with each other when they
were hungry when they needed more food
when they're sleepy i mean
so
so maybe let's maybe we should tune the
question a little tighter and ask
uh maybe
basic discoveries could be communicated
but not subtle nuances of discoveries
which would require a more sophisticated
way of communication what do you think
of that
that's my answer and i'm sticking to it
it's a good answer i think we would find
those nuances because the same way we
found nuances for when you're deaf
or when you're blind we always seem to
find a way to communicate with each
other as as as human beings and even if
we didn't have that we would just find a
way to communicate those nuances
it would be interesting to look at yeah
written language and technology and if
they follow a similar curve
if there's a certain like limiting
factor i don't know but i will say that
i want to just deconstruct the question
in terms of what is language because i
think that we have a very
narrow definition of that um in terms of
like what is human written language and
and uh and the ways that we communicate
so that's what i say i say yeah that's
your question re-tinker the language of
your question
and then we'll we'll re-answer it
that's a nice day damn just send them
back to the drawing chester hey ally
we have to be here next week okay
chester i think it's a good question
chester i do
i do
i just want to deconstruct a little bit
how about this how about this let me let
me leapfrog this and say
science as we now think of it
took great leaps and advances only after
scientific journals became the common
way
discoveries were shared
not only within a country but across
national boundaries speaking whatever
was the agreed upon language of the day
right and you go back several hundred
years it was latin
the language of the erudite and the
scientific communication that's when it
really took a
took a jump so i have to say
whether or not it's spoken language the
simple act of communicating a discovery
at a distance mattered greatly there you
go and you're right you know what's
that's so
interesting because that's where the
codification comes in
is the fact that you're able to have
these you know um
records
so that you can go back and compare and
then compare across distances you don't
have to reinvent something next we have
the record right not only the record of
what's been discovered but the record of
of of
dead ends so you don't have to repeat
the mistakes of people who came before
you
fascinating
great job right okay all right keep
going that was awesome all right here we
go uh tom says
um c-e-z so i don't know
[Music]
i think
being
nice
it's better for teaching the scientific
method
what were were no sorry what are the
verified experiments showing which
teaching methods
are best
uh
yeah so so ali what's this field
i mean other than the field of education
is there an ology associated with that
i
think i had
i had bill nye on pedo
just started just started he's just
starting out in his career okay that's
right
we talked about science communication
and um
he
essentially was talking about how
you shouldn't introduce a concept with a
big word first you should talk about the
concept first and then define it instead
of just dropping a big word essentially
i think not alienating people is the
biggest hurdle to get over with science
communication so i guess i would err on
the side of being nice
in terms of
trying to be as inclusive as possible
and have it be a welcoming space because
i think one thing about science that
intimidates people
especially lay people is they think that
scientists are all in lab coats they
know everything they don't break
anything they don't make any mistakes
they don't fail at anything they're just
imbued with knowledge they don't realize
it's inaccessible inaccessible to them
they don't realize that scientists are
just really curious people who do a lot
of experiments that
mess up a lot until they find an answer
so i think trying to come at it from a
more humanistic like
hop on board learn what you can instead
of get out of here
i'd like that rather than think of it as
something up on the ivory tower hill
yeah that you have no access to very
good all right and i also think the more
varied
backgrounds we have in science the
different questions people ask i think
if you have the same people in science
they're going to ask the same kind of
questions of their experiments and i
think that's one thing i really love
about genealogy is having all these
different types of scientists who
approach their research
based on their own background so yeah i
think
hop on in we need as many scientists as
possible so
nice
nice is better okay i think no i agree
all right
all right very cool so uh thanks for the
uh supercilious answer ally i don't know
english humor
loved it
here we go steven som summers wants to
know this he says hey
say you've spoken on tv or a podcast to
a huge audience with total confidence in
your idea only to find out later
that you got something wrong
how do you set the record straight when
that happens
that's a great question that is a great
question
one thing i recommend if people struggle
with this is just
take what you need from your house and
go live in a cave for the rest of your
life
don't show your face again remove
yourself from society uh you've failed
it's all over is what i would say um no
that's not me
i
i think you know i think one thing that
a lot of people don't realize is that
science is evolving there are so many
things we thought about science and then
we did more experiments and learned
something else and so understanding that
science and just knowledge human
knowledge is
always elastic it's always changing you
may have been wrong that's great admit
it
cop to it issue a correction on twitter
and instagram and on your website and
move on with your life i think um wait
but not ollie there are two kinds of
wrongs one of them is right this is what
we think is true today but more research
may undo it later
and so yeah i say well three years ago i
got i got that wrong because that's the
best we knew at the time that's
different from
blunder where you just simply say
something that's just flat out wrong and
someone calls calls you out later on so
that's a more of an embarrassing kind of
error to do should that person move to
the cave forever i would say remember
every human is a human
everyone makes mistakes and uh you know
they say there's a fixed mindset and a
growth mindset one is like uh too afraid
to make
make mistakes others i make a mistake
and i move on from it so i think the
best thing you can do is admit your
wrongs apologize for them sincerely and
put out a correction and so so we have
to work on that mindset that's a mindset
that people
fear i think because you know what it
what is it they said that the scariest
thing
even scarier than death is speaking in
public yes for some people yeah i never
understood that because i i never had an
issue with that i mean you think people
would rather be
at the front of the room at their own
funeral than
giving the eulogy to somebody else's
then in the front of the room of of a
full house uh right okay yeah
and so i mean unless there is a sniper
or you're gonna die straight up of a
heart attack at the speaking podium
you'll be fine i always say that um
you know the we're definitely
so afraid of things that can't hurt us i
remember i made a flow chart once of
like can this thing kill you
if yes run if no chill out those are the
basics i did an episode i love that flow
chart it's a great flow chart it i use
it all the time but i did an episode um
two-parter called fearology with someone
named mary poffenroth and she's an
expert in fear and the amygdala and how
we react to fear and it was
life-changing she is so great and she
essentially said most of our fears and
anxiety and stress is just worried that
we're not good enough and so if you
think about everyone walking around
worrying that they're not good enough to
do their job or follow their dreams or
start a conversation or a podcast or
correct their mistakes then you know
that's a whole lot of stress that we
have that we can i got one for you chuck
yeah ready
what flat what flat earthers
fear most is sphere itself
by the way that joke made me believe the
earth is flat
did you just come up with that or did
you no i tweeted that a couple of years
ago and
no no it was i think it's been around
it's been around but the only thing we
have to do
is
sphere itself
actually i'm just hearing something
that's pretty damn clever so yeah yeah
that's good it's the it's
fear it's sphere is what does it yeah
from the word play i like it
all right we got time maybe one more
question what else you got chuck yeah
let's go to kayla slaughter
kayla says
by the way these are all patreon members
right yes that is correct and yeah
because uh let me just tell people that
you can go to
star
patreon.comtalk
support us there if you come in at a
certain um support level um
we uh we take your questions and we read
them on the air and that allows us to i
mean they bribe us to uh to ask their
questions that's what that is that's
listen yeah neither neither nobody in
this organization is a law enforcement
official
there is no law that says we cannot take
bribes
all right
next question
she says i'll be starting a family soon
i want to make sure my children have a
well-rounded experience in science and
politics and every all theologies
basically
any thoughts on how i can start
early
i
wish that paper encyclopedias were still
around because i feel like when i was a
kid all i wanted was an encyclopedia
shelf in our house just to take a volume
and then just go sit under a tree with
it but i guess so you're 75 years old
i'm one million years old yeah i'm uh
that is good
but we had papers
but books were made of paper
smell them with your nose we did have an
old we we finally got one from a garage
sale but it was so outdated that it was
like one day
human men will be on the moon and i
remember being like yes yeah i love that
i love the out-of-date things they're
fun
they're cheap but um uh i would say i
would say let them frolic let them
frolic get them get them a microscope
because you start swabbing window sills
and start looking at fly mouth parts you
start to realize the world is a lot
bigger and smaller than we than we think
so i'd say let them frolic fly mouth
parts that was very random right there
of all the things you could have listed
fly mouth parts
i don't even no no i'd retract the
question i don't want to know how you
came up with that in your list have you
ever looked at them what are you doing
later today get yourself a microscope
find a dead flock july
mouth parts
you know they just they're thinking
about them barfing on a sandwich and
sucking it back up the world is big and
small it's beautiful
it's great get him a maybe get him a
telescope and a microscope and then so
you want this should be
free range
free range children yeah with access to
the large and the small yes and in those
limits there are no bounds nice
and i wanna i wanna make it known
that i don't have kids so okay take this
with a grain of salt because i don't
know how to write
we we i heard in offline that you have a
dog i do i have an eight-year-old
daughter she's a poodle yeah and does
does your eight-year-old poodle daughter
have a microscope she does yeah she has
a microscope
she's doing great she's got infrared
goggles i got her a uh yeah an electron
scanning microscope we just keep in the
garage um yeah so she's she's got
everything she needs uh by the way kayla
has a a follow-up for you ali she says
what's it like talking to so many smart
people all of the time and by the way i
love your shows
plural she put
yeah what it's like talking to smart
people all the time is incredibly
incredibly humbling so it's it's there's
nothing better than being reminded that
you're uh the stupidest person in a
conversation and that's what i do for a
living it's great um so yeah i love it
that reminds me of a quote if you're the
smartest person in the room
find another room yeah
that's a good thing that's that's what
you're saying here ollie right
you're reveling in the fact
that
every outing you learn something
absolutely for so many people the pain
of learning something new
is unbearable to them and so they stay
steeped in their ignorance ossified from
the graduation day from when they left
school that's true living in the past
living in a shell of their former attack
is there such a thing as a stupid
question
no i really don't think so i think if
it's honest
if it's honest and vulnerable it's not
stupid and chances are someone else in
the room has it and
we're all going to die anyway we're all
going to be bones and dust and a fungus
is going to be
yes
that's how i live my life cut bangs wow
that's very crunchy but true we're all
going to die you're going to be powdery
no one's going to remember you i don't
even remember my great grandparents name
so why would i be like i don't want to
ask this question about uh you know
solar power or about the
you on that universe okay someone said
i'm afraid to do this you're going to
die anyway yeah i'm going to die you're
going to die literally a fungus you're
going to die anyway
your fungus lunch at the end of the day
ask a question and learn something who
if someone laughs they're a jerk so it's
great just do your life all right wait a
minute i got to tell you okay i got to
tell the story real quick because it's
speaking of stupid questions now you
just reminded me you're going to die
okay i have i have evidence to refute
that where somewhere outdoors it's neil
and i and these people who are huge fans
they come over they're talking to him
he's being very very gracious spending
way too much time talking to him and so
the guy says
hey
do you have one of those apps on your
phone where you can hold it up to the
sky and it will show you constellations
and the meal goes like this
are you kidding me right now
and i was like yeah bro he is the app
i'm like are you insane you're asking
you're asking neil degrasse tyson does
he need an app on his phone to look at
the night sky i'm like brother he is
what is your problem
yes
yeah my answer is in my day we have to
remember where the constellations were
i still i think embarrassing moment for
him but still there's a lot of stars up
there if anyone's taught us that it's
you so
he learned something about you that he
your brain has even more capacity than
he ever imagined and also he learned he
needs the app you don't yes thank you
there you go okay and this bit about
being fungus lunch i'm trying to decide
whether that's a happy note or a sad
note it is
it's amazingly liberating it's i did a
whole episode on thanatology death and
dying one of the happiest episodes i did
i came out of there saying well i'm just
going to do whatever i want to do
so yeah
your fungus lunch ask a question do your
thing
follow your passion
you know
read the encyclopedia it's all fine
and remember you're delicious
to some organism you're delicious
all right we're going to take a quick
break when we come back more stock talk
with allie ward
hey star talk fans this next segment of
our episode with algie's host ali ward
is sponsored by the all-electric
chevrolet bull euv the everyday electric
vehicle for everyday people that's you
the all-electric chevy bolt euv has so
many cool features including the ability
to engage in conversations hands-free
with the industry's first hands-free
driving assistance technology you can
find out more at chevrolet.com
electric slash bolt dash euv all right
let's get back to the show
we're back star talk cosmic queries and
for this segment we're going to actually
devote this
to a discussion about electric cars
chuck what do you think of that yes
that's awesome because i know you don't
like the word awesome but in this case i
think it is awe inspiring there but just
to be clear i i love the word awesome
but when properly applied like when you
discover a new universe or something but
okay when people say it would be awesome
if you could pass the salt that is not a
good use of the word awesome okay okay
here is a good use of the word awesome
because electric vehicles actually do so
much to help the environment and i care
about the environment i know you do
people don't think i do but this segment
we're doing in partnership with the
all-new chevrolet bolt euv
so i'm just over the moon because we get
to talk about electric vehicles man and
that's our future all right so this euv
is that like suv except electric is that
how are you yeah
yeah exactly doesn't sound better though
doesn't sound better to be like the uuv
you know auv
yeah
so yeah let's get back to our guest here
ali ward from ologies who basically did
a did a land grab on all ologies in the
universe
that's a straight power move
that's total gangster right there
once you get the handle you're sitting
on it and it's yours but yeah this would
be electric vehicle technology i suppose
the the segment could be
the ology okay
you just cram that ology in whether or
not it belongs yep that's what i do
someone mentioned something in casual
conversation and i tell you what all
agita is but this one is really exciting
to me
i've been excited about um electric
vehicles since i was a kid my my dad is
really into
alternative sources of power and solar
power and so i have been watching for
years
and
seeing how evs come on the market so i'm
really excited about the chevrolet volt
eevee i think eb is a good move too i
like the way it sounds and but is it
like 100 grand like other electric
vehicles like what's going on there
that's the great thing about it
otherwise it's not for everybody you
can't take that chevy to the levee if it
costs that much nobody's
no good old boys are doing that so yeah
well that's why they just the price
point on this that's why they drained
the living was to pay for your very
expensive which this is not actually
when i said it's accessible that's what
i mean it's uh you know this is a a car
that allows people to enter into this
realm
and if you're a conscientiousness as a
first a foray okay very good very good
yeah so so ali do you have a question
related to this i do actually i
wanted to well wait actually that's not
fair because you're our guest and we
usually take questions from the audience
from our fan base but but you know you
seem so into it maybe we'll give you the
occasion to ask the question with the
permission of our fan base i think
they'll allow it okay go ahead so the
floor is mine i have the cosmic query
conch right now and can
launch a question okay so i wanted to
talk about whether or not electric
vehicles are good for the environment
how much good do they do over
a car that runs on fossil fuels
what are your thoughts
yeah yeah so i can i mean i don't claim
to be the world's expert on that but i
can get you a lot of the way towards an
answer to that question
so
uh here here's the problem
transportation today
you know cars and trucks and things that
that move
commerce but i guess even trains but
some trains are electric so let's just
stick to the ones that have sort of
engines that burn fossil fuels uh the
problem is
if you have a car that
takes gasoline it can only run on
gasoline
right so if so if you run out of gas you
got to go to a gas station and fill it
up with gasoline
so
you know we all know how much gas cost
and we know where it comes from in the
world and we know if a pipeline gets
shut down or we know if a war breaks out
and we know of
an oil well is on fire and we know if
there's new regulation related to it
so
oil has become a strategic commodity
simply because we need it
to run a transportation grid so now in
comes an electric car
so an electric car of course it still
uses power all right so so what's up
with that why is it good rather than
sort of neutral or bad or equal right so
here's what happens you got your car and
it's at home and you plug it in
okay
now
it's getting electricity from your power
plant
there's a chance your power plant is
using coal there's a good chance of that
all right so that's not really much
better
all right coal burning coal or burning
gasoline there's still this carbon
footprint okay however
the power plant is not limited to just
coal if they wanted to and many have
they can put in if they have sunlight
where you are a
solar farm or with a wind farm if you're
near water you could be hydroelectric
all of these sources of power
can be generated by your power company
and show up in your wall socket
so you don't need 12 different engines
in your car
to use 12 different kinds of energy
you just need a plug
that gives you access to the thing
that's generating the energy 12
different ways
so
if you electrify the transportation grid
you are future proofing our path in into
a a culture in a civilization that can
wean itself off its dependence of fossil
fuels and so that's why it works that's
why it's good
i like that answer not to mention if you
go solar on your house you essentially
have a solar-powered car which
is a car powered by the sun there you go
exactly there's got to be a bumper
sticker for that
like solar-powered vehicle
yeah that wouldn't work in places like
seattle where the sun never comes out or
upstate new york uh but yeah it would be
believable if it's in a place where the
sun is is prevalent so so that's why
uh electric is good now the problem is
i can have a gallon of gas
over here
and i can move it over there
where you need it
okay you can't do that
with the like you can't carry
electricity with you oh so you can
charge your battery and then i can move
the battery over there no the battery's
in the car
okay so
so
one of the problems with electricity as
it's generated is
it can only
you can't sort of store it outside of
the battery that's in your car
so to run your lights to run most of the
things that
civilization uses electricity for it
doesn't come out of a storage battery
it's generated on the fly as you need it
from the power station and delivered by
the high tension lines i was going to
say like i'm glad you said that because
there's a lot of people who are
you know um electric vehicle hesitant i
will say because they're worried about
how far they can drive like because of
what you just said and the cool thing uh
about the industry but more importantly
about the
chevy bolt euv is the because i know
this because i got to take a tour of the
car with gm but the cool thing is this
car has nearly 250 mile range on a full
charge
250. right that's good
that'll get you between any adjacent
cities i mean new york city is 250
between uh boston and washington right
and you're in la ali what what cities
with it san diego is easy oh um
if you need to make a getaway that's
palm springs that's joshua tree that's
santa barbara that's yeah excuse me
joshua tree oh excuse me
okay
excuse me i'm about to take my chevrolet
bolt euv down to the joshua tree
sometimes you need an instagram shoot
you need to get in your bowl i love the
euvs i think if you like a hatchback
with a little bit higher profile um
yeah i love that and the range is great
they call it range anxiety people who
are afraid to go ev because they think
they're going to be stranded but once
you drive an electric it's kind of like
once you become a bird watcher you start
seeing all these charging stations just
like you would see birds you didn't
realize were there before but once you
drive an ev it's like oh there's a char
they're everywhere you can charge in
parking lots at the mall you can charge
next to your grocery store you can
charge at hotels it's just like but so
the bird watcher analog there is
if you've never looked for a bird you
would never know it was there until you
knew what to look for yeah and then
they're everywhere i got you okay so
that's like a psychological effect sort
of once you know what to look for but
yeah there's ev charging stations
everywhere yeah there's about 40 000 uh
birds to look for
when you're traveling
is that how many is that how many uh ev
stations are there yeah yeah there's
about 40 000 public charging stations so
you know
okay so
so chuck which which goes faster down
the road
a chevy bolt or usain bolt
you know
i'm gonna say that the usain bolt is
faster out of the blocks but the chevy
bolt is going to ultimately smoke them
don't tell him that exactly not to
mention you don't need as many carbs for
your chevy bolt you can you don't have
to run it on pasta protein anything i
think range oh i gotcha there you go
yeah for sure so was that that's your
only question you had uh well that was
my main question about it i think um
you know people who are considering
going from
a fossil fuel car to something that is
electric i think tend to be people who
are environmentally conscious and so
they really want to know
how much better is this for the
environment but knowing i agree and
those are the people who do it first but
ultimately if you get the right price
point people just do it because it's the
right price point right yeah oh wait so
then
you know speaking of what you just said
before we actually got on the show today
ali was doing something on your computer
where you were like looking at the
savings
so when you talk about price point there
are hidden savings in
every electric vehicle uh but i don't
know do you have what are you doing well
there are fewer moving parts oh can i
can i back up real quick we're running
out of time i don't want to take up the
whole thing but but uh michael faraday
go back a hundred and
fifty sixty years when you sit back
back in the show
you're like can i go back michael
faraday
so michael faraday an english scientist
physicist
he basically is responsible for figuring
out how to generate electricity
and he he invented the concept of an
electric field by the way because that's
not a thing you can touch right it's
just this thing there and so he can draw
it and calculate you can calculate with
it so he he realized that if you move a
wire through a magnetic field it induces
current
in that wire and you can it'll show up
on a meter and so
whoa well that's kind of it was a little
novel at the time but what would you do
with this this is kind of a stupid toy
and then people figure oh my gosh this
is the birth of the electrification of
the world
point is
the way we do that now is we have a
tightly wound
you know what's called a turbine a
tightly wound wire coil
that spins in a magnetic field and an
electric um uh current is induced in
that wire
ever since the beginning of electricity
we've known how to
spin things
that's that's what we do best we've been
doing it for 150 years and what is a car
if not electricity spinning things
so
the acceleration on an electric vehicle
can be excellent because of this fact
and that's why the chevy bulk i didn't
check the acceleration numbers they
might actually accelerate out of the
blocks faster than usain bolt now now
that i'm thinking about it
so
well also uh i was checking on price
point stuff just to see how much wood
i save
per year
driving an eevee and my parents live
about 400 miles away so i go up
a couple times obviously like every
month or two and i would save 10 000
over five years on gas
just based on that which is um yeah if
you're calculating not to mention how
much co2 that is right i know right so a
little karmically and then pocketbook
wise but yeah i i did they have a number
cruncher for you so you don't have to
you don't have to pull out your
spreadsheets they have it for you i see
what you did when you say karma
karmically yeah do you like that
yeah
electric the puns are electric
so guys we got to land this plane or
park this car
[Laughter]
so ally's been delight to have you on
this show i can't believe we haven't had
you ever on before we got to do this
again with your permission yes and talk
about some of the ologies that you've
you've discovered or i think you're
inventing some of those ologies
maybe bending some words i think i think
you're pulling them out i don't know
where
i swear i do look for
i do look for them in the literature
first i promise but yes so many
allergies to cover i'm here whenever you
need me
it's in so little time yes okay
excellent thanks for being on star talk
thank you dad you can catch your honor
ology podcast and um it goes everywhere
i mean every ology you can ever imagine
it's even the ones you haven't imagined
because she made them up they're
there right chuck always good to have
you man hey neil before we wrap up i
just want to let the viewer know that if
you're ready to make the electric future
part of your present do some good for
the environment which is what it is all
about check out the chevrolet ball euv
at
chevrolet.com
electric chevrolet.com electric do some
good people come on all right this has
been star talk cosmic aquarius neil
degrasse tyson here as always
keep looking up
[Music]